what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation once again joined by Tara
Erickson how are you I hate you I'm good
here's my Goosebumps t-shirt what are we
watching today ghost
Rider similar to our Fantastic Four
experience I had only seen this one one
time 2007 needless to say I only
remember one scene and I'll get it out
of the way right now it's Nicholas
Cage's Marvel body shot and that's only
because my friend's girlfriend made a
really funny comment when it happened
other than that I can't tell you what
happens in this movie so I'm excited to
re-watch for the first time but this is
Tara's first time watching this neither
of us have seen the sequel so if this
goes well we'll watch spirit of
Vengeance and we'll see how chaotic that
experience is are you excited Tara I'm
excited there's a guy on fire on the
poster do you know anything about Ghost
Rider no nothing that's exciting ladies
and gentlemen leave a like leave a like
and uh special to do that if you want to
watch spirit of Vengeance and if you
want to make sure you get notified for a
spirit of entrance
[Music]
ring that Bell I wonder what the
retention is of how many people actually
subscribe because you did full length
Reaction watch song where you single
with your own copy of Ghost Rider
available for super sexy rejects over at
our patreon page thank you to all who
have joined because we've covered so
many movies and some stuff over there as
well awful and you know what I have to
say the same stuff all the time just to
say thank you got exclusive stuff over
there we covered reaction all right
let's watch songs Google let's get to it
Oh that's oh sweet oh all right Marvel
get it tall tales that help us make
sense of things too great we're too
terrifying to believe sounds like
Santa's voiceover is the best it has to
be Sam Elliott right yeah it sounds like
him some damn Soul cursed to ride the
Earth
collecting on the devil's deals the
devil is in Mephisto a ghost rider was
sent to the Village of San venganza but
that contract was so powerful he knew he
could never let the devil get his hands
on it
whoa
[Music]
the Outland the devil he ghosted the
devil yeah man the devil deserved it the
thing about Legends is
sometimes they're true
I'm just gonna say I already love
everything this is fun
it's like a Gothic horror action movie
yeah oh my God I need a Ghostwriter
t-shirt and I haven't even watched the
movie yet
[Music]
oh my God he's like Johnny Storm
[Applause]
it looks like Chris Evans yeah
hot shot angel boy and you do things
without thinking you ain't making the
choice the choice is making you I was
just doing it for the crowd both know
why you've done it there are themes here
she's going to stand by you when you're
in a wheelchair
I mean it just ran over a rock right hey
that one rock could have led to a
concussion yeah right man
what's wrong Roxy
I'm leaving
my dad's sending me to live with my mom
this is where you kill her
[Laughter]
we'll jump on the back and just keep
going
but what about your dad
show he doesn't
need tomorrow noon we'll meet here
oh young love so sweet
bound to end
God he actually loves him
but I bet you he's never hugged him that
would be too gay Tara
he's dying
oh
sweet oh my goodness
all right
worried about your father
about cancer is the time it takes
Nate do you see that oh yeah what if I
could
make him better give me a price
I'll take
your soul yeah by sunrise tomorrow your
father will be healthy as a horse
all you have to do is
inside
when the dad eventually die just from
old age yeah but he wasn't that old
ah
well that'll do just fine
morning sleeping beauty healthy as a
horse you look great right I've been
sick son I'm not anymore I can't explain
it but I feel healthy as a horse
that's exactly what the devil said
girlfriend's gonna have to wait
all right
uh what
oh my God so the devil was like I'm
gonna make him well but you I didn't say
he'd be around for like more than a day
what a meanie dead dead
okay
so the person he makes the deal whoa
the person makes a deal with is also the
villain that's interesting one day when
I need you
I will come
I'll be watching oh
she doesn't even know about his dad
is he just gonna keep riding oh my gosh
you're not gonna at least ride up there
and be like yo my dad died and also I
made a deal with the devil but like
literally
what
uh okay you can't live in fear
you can't live in fear
it's a southern rat Nicholas Cage
[Music]
like how
oh like the devil gets him across
okay
whoa
oh my God that was so painful oh my gosh
holy junk damn the real stunt man do
that [__] that looks so painful whoa
that had to be like CGI right because
that looked insane heck is it back okay
but it's fine
thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my God
call it Mr Invincible it'll have to be
At a next jump Johnny Blaze will attempt
to clear for the length of a football
field from field goal to field goal
field goal to field goal no way possible
there's no way he'll die
you should be taking a dirt nap after
that Ragdoll day I got lucky luck don't
cover it JB
and you got an angel looking after you
yeah maybe a dark angel
maybe it's something else
[Laughter]
AKA Satan hell yeah
[Music]
you wear him Venom shirt
oh my God hell's freezing over I think
you might be lost boy you got a problem
with that as a matter of fact
everybody
Wicked all right cool Wes Bentley that's
that actor's name it took me a while can
I just turn this music off for a minute
Mac you touch the Carpenters or that
chimp video again we got a scrap on our
hands
at least promise me you'll think about
taking the cars out I'll think about it
man oh cool
[Music]
what is the purpose of why you're doing
this just for fun hello Russell
what why are you here
another like Elemental villains I've
come for the contract of Santa ganza
and when we find it then what then we'll
take this world what about
Mephistopheles
there's some cool designs
but Johnny Blaze don't do no interviews
okay not even for an old friend
who this girl
okay
whoever Mendes that's right from high
school I forgot that was her what's
going through your mind right now
you look really good Johnny what drives
somebody to risk their life for
entertainment I heard you got married
most of the time the Press focuses on
the crashes the cost of what you do
there any other costs
uh
yeah
oh my God
so Nicholas Cage
I'm gonna stay for the job bro you know
we gotta get back plus I never liked
watching you jump
ouch what did he ever do to you he just
loved her thank God you listen to me
take the cars out would have been
otherwise
will not be jumping 50 cars
but instead we'll be leaving six
why JB why helicopters man instead of
the cars or the ring of fire I
helicopter
my dad thought it'd be cool
how much noise did you put in the tanks
enough to change the space shuttle Keith
go ahead
let's go all right man
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow off to the interstate he goes
now do it again yeah
[Music]
I made it pull over
[Laughter]
this is really dangerous for that helmet
Johnny
[Applause]
[Music]
still like Italian Italian look you were
17 and you witnessed a tragedy and you
ran I have no hard feelings none you
know and that's why they call it the
past because it's past it's done it's
over with
wow all right there's a restaurant in my
hotel the Plaza
eight o'clock yes
oh my gosh Nicholas Cage
oh my gosh yes
oh my goodness Mephistopheles I knew
you'd come long time no see boys a
Memphis stoplight so it is Mephisto okay
it's my contract
we both know you can't harm me here
you will suffer for this you guys are
hurting each other's Optics
I will retire him just like I will
retire you father ah it's a lot of
visuals all right for five lines of
dialogue a lot of lights on lights off
type of situation
[Music]
oh my God is he gonna stand her up that
would be hilarious you made that job no
one else made that job you're the best
writer you deserve a second chance
she's a sign
come on man like how long is this pep
talk been is he on fire now
this is so cringy come on man terrible
why aren't you there Johnny can you
imagine standing her up I know I
wouldn't ever
sweet I barely know how to ride a
bicycle
[Music]
Hello Johnny
stay away from me
you're like a semi Elvis thing
I'm the one known as Blackheart I'm not
doing it you don't have any choice
oh Wicked wow
the true meaning of burning rubber
holy [__] oh my goodness
foreign
[Music]
political messaging happen here
what happened to the graves they moved
them
Michael's Church
whoa
oh let's see it
[Music]
that's cool
all right
you're going down
I don't think so
what
[Music]
oh Jesus
I mean you can't really kill a ghost you
ain't so tough
have mercy sorry all out in Mercy
oh awesome
whoa
cool whoa that's pretty awesome Ash
Embers yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
it's like a like a pet a motorcycle pet
oh my gosh oh wow okay
it's got a skull oh my goodness
oh my God that's great
so aesthetically cool give me the damn
bag
[Applause]
I forget her name Rebel Wilson yeah that
it is yeah guilty
die now
[Music]
oh that's really cool developing him in
the nightmares that he has induced
[Music]
man you're gonna have to be making a lot
of stops
not bad 2007. cool transition for back
in the day
oh
Sam Elliott
oh is this a cemetery they're looking
for yes the answer to hear other
questions last night did happen and it
will happen again you are the writer the
Ghost Rider get used to it kid it'll be
a lot easier
how does he know all this yeah like he's
very well informed writers the devil's
Bounty Hunter
since I hunt down anyone that escaped
from hell why does it have to be Johnny
Storm though could it be anyone
it seems like it's not Johnny Storm
specific it was um
Punk and I could see all the wrong you
never done
turned it all against him the pin and
steer
Penance there last one was 150 years ago
a little town called San benganza the
straighter came along making promises
consumed by agreed they turned on one
another Sam Ellie makes it so much more
believable yeah
thanks for the info I feel much better
now that I know I'm the devil's Bounty
Hunter
oh my God that's all from his flames
[Music]
that's right when he was going through
all that oh yeah it's like a
gravitational pull of stuff his face was
a skull
yeah like
let me apologize last night was
inexcusable
College I got a great job you're just
the same
eyes really that blue I was just
wondering that that has got to be like
some CGI blue in there hey Captain I got
something a license plate it's probably
for one of these cars that was destroyed
yeah this is the moment I remember oh
dang
holy junk
he did get very fit it's like Is that
real cut right
that's crazy it doesn't look real it
really doesn't
but his stomach is moving when he does
that like it clenches like it is
all right Nick Cage we see you give me
control
over the possessing
oh no whoa
I came to apologize
I'm leaving town tonight and uh
I didn't want what I said today to be
the last words between us
she's apologizing
to him yeah it's insane why was he just
like you don't have to apologize
I remember that day
terrified that my dad was gonna come in
yeah God not enough women are like her
and Jessica Alba from Fantastic
why he can't get attached man he's the
Ghost Rider oh my God you almost kill
yourself on the highway so you can ask
me out and then you don't show
then keep my picture
but when I kiss you you try to shove me
out the door what's
what's going on tell her you're the
Ghost Rider tell her you can control
fire I saw my soul of the devil I knew I
had to spare you spare me from what the
devil on account I work for him that's
why I couldn't make it to dinner
[Laughter]
it was Bounty Hunter but it only happens
at night whenever I'm around evil evil
people evil spirits
have changed into just show her the fire
in your hand he's a creepy monster but I
am learning to I'm getting control of it
this is your excuse
for the past
for last night
for everything it's the truth Roxanne
yeah man he's working for the devil just
show her the fire truck she'll believe
you I don't know why he's not doing that
I realize that you'd rather make up
ridiculous stories and be honest with me
and I walk out of that door
forever
goodbye forever
man you should go after her when you're
when you're Ghost Rider yeah also just
light if you just let your hand on fire
it all would have been fine
you're coming with us
okay
this guy was three years from retirement
never harmed a flying his life in fact
neither did most of the corpses turning
up since you came home you son of a
[__]
[Music]
provide a very very important civil
service in fact when I finished my stone
career I intend to apply my skills to
being a motorcycle policeman
what do they have on him I don't know
because they found the license plate
remember so there's so much no I know
please please you don't want to put me
in there sorry the rich was booked
they're all going to be lit on fire
buddy please get me out of here
oh God he can see all their bad stuff
oh man leave him alone
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa
nice jacket
very nice
how do you ensure the jacket doesn't
catch on fire
[Music]
yeah let the kid out
his sweater said Wicked jester
sweet awesome
run kid run oh man all this first
opportunity to get out of there really
dang it whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
I wonder if Nicholas Cage did mocap for
this
he's supposed to be doing good but
everywhere he goes is excessive property
damage he's destroying the city you've
been protecting it all these years it's
foreign a secrecy want to keep it from
the likes of you
oh
I really do enjoy the look of this movie
a lot yeah
yeah it's badass
what yeah man what is it gonna like turn
into a boat oh my gosh it can ride
underwater shut up
oh
my gosh shut up you hear the middle
finger that is awesome
oh [__]
oh my goodness
oh that's cool anything
you're gonna get blamed for that yep
Johnny
[Music]
that's not doing good Johnny
you're pissing me off sorry
[Music]
oh oh
You released him oh yeah all right all
you have to do is apologize to the Ghost
Rider
you cannot catch the wind
ah
whoa
dope I love how they try to hang him
with that chain and that chain has
become his Ultimate Weapon
whoa that was a cool shot
hundreds of people just had glass fall
on them
foreign
[Music]
awesome Legend has it he was a Texas
Ranger but he got greedy Slade made a
deal ended up a Ghost Rider remember
that contract The Stranger made with the
people's son to Gonza yes but what he
found there was so evil that he took the
contract black card is coming stay away
from friends and family anybody he can
use against it because he will you
should not have walked near her in her
Direction
okay well lately he's been reading these
really weird books and he's writing
stuff down and he's staying up late and
he he does it over here you can go
through this stuff and I don't know if
it means anything she'll figure it out
she's a journalist yeah she does the
news
why are you gasping because that's what
she does in this not even close
I liked it I know he was great
that is hot so now I must take it
now I'm gonna break it oh
look into my eyes your pen and stare
doesn't work on me
I guess I guess caretaker forgot to
mention that huh
caretakers Sam Elliott
you work for me
get the contract from the caretaker
bring it to me in San benganza and maybe
I'll spare your girl's life
gotta get the contract from Carter Slade
where's the contract I can't end this
without it
he may have my soul but he doesn't have
my spirit
I did it for the right reason
then that makes you dangerous
get you unpredictable
best thing you can be right now
right now damn Sam Elliott he's so good
he really elevates this
what
oh snap
[Music]
oh this is cool
I got one last ride left in me
[Music]
oh
my goodness
you keeper
[Music]
that's right
oh my God yes was that predictable
because I didn't I did not see that
coming I did not see that color a little
bit when he took it out of the shovel
but
oh that is sweet
hahaha
[Music]
just like on fire stick to the Shadows
the end of the trail for me he just rode
there yeah I guess he just escorted him
to the place I guess all I can do now is
hope he sees fit to give me a second
chance thank you kid
I'm gonna ride back normally punch this
horse okay I thought they were gonna
like I thought we're gonna like get a
Crazy Action Figure yeah
well that was easy one down that was
really that was
remarkably easy peace
thought he was going to die and then he
was like fire come to me and it did stop
you've changed she dies
ouch
all right
light it on fire
yeah oh sweet cool
looks like you're out of time
[Music]
oh
they still got a gun this is the
contract of San veganza
come to me
whoa
absorbing all the souls he's just gonna
be a vessel for all them how is this a
good idea
[Music]
I don't feel like you thought this
through man no we have to wait till all
the bad Souls get in him and then kill
him right or are they all just like out
in the open now I mean he's trying to
take them all in yeah so if he gets them
all and then we kill him then I guess we
kill them all
[Music]
my name is
why why you because he's the Ghost Rider
God damn it I'm the only one who can
walk in both worlds
a Ghost Rider run
[Music]
oh is there Holy Water Somewhere all of
your world all of your souls will be
mine now
oh hell yeah all right roll it
flame bullets yeah man
what
is that
what is happening what is going on are
they leaving or going into the thing
whoa what is this how does it feel to
have all that evil inside of you
a thousand souls to burn oh yeah yes yes
your souls are stained by the blood of
the innocent
dude you're hurting hard right now devil
that's clever
hahaha
[Music]
that's hot
congratulations Johnny
it's time I take back the power of the
Ghost Rider what let someone else carry
this curse you're free now no
no
and I'm gonna use it against you I will
make you pay for this
can't live in fear
yeah
[Music]
devil just can't take it away
it's not
oh because he can possess the member
he's like give me possession of it sure
[Music]
is what you always were meant to be
got your second chance
go out there and make the best of it
save lives what about your career for
her for him uh all that money too oh
yeah
he's got like millions of dollars he
could probably do some good and
dispensing some of that around you know
Legends are a way of understanding
things greater than ourselves this is
how Legends are born
all right all righty
all righty written and directed by Mark
Stevens Stephen did the whole thing well
Tara
what did you think brag what did you
think we'll wait for a postcard fun
I liked it I liked it too yeah I mean
there's like of course it's not like wow
amazing acting but you're right about uh
Elliot wait what's his name Sam Elliott
yeah yeah Sam Elliott uh he does really
Elevate the film he's a fantastic actor
and
um I loved seeing Nick Cage just do Nick
Cage things like when he takes that long
pause in the beginning in the interview
and he's like
yeah I'm like oh my God that's such a
Nick Cage thing and he's like yeah
it's so like I just I love that I love
how he plays it like a boy yes like a
kid the whole time is it's kind of like
a curious Lost Boy is how you play the
entire performance
yeah I agree but sometimes when I look
at it I mean in this performance I'm
like but doesn't he do that a lot yeah I
mean but he but he doesn't he does have
like a newfound wonder you're right he
plays kind of like a crazy guy yeah like
a crazy man right but here he's he's
just like a soft-spoken boy who's thrown
into these like wacky situations I
thought it was so much fun this is this
is pretty wild because
um
uh I I thought that like some of it
would come back to me as we're watching
it you know like like a Fantastic Four
there was like three scenes I remember
when hold on
it's credit
okay there were like three scenes I
remember when like oh okay this is
coming back to me at this this moment
this moment and none of it was coming
back none of it yeah the whole time I
was like are you sure you saw it I'm
pretty sure yeah I'm pretty sure I saw I
remember because I remember a very
specific comment on my friend's
girlfriend made when we were watching it
uh it was it was that shirtless scene so
it's always stood in my memory she was
like oh gross because it just like
looked unnatural and that for some
reason that's always stuck in my Noggin
um but it did look unreal like it
doesn't look real right fit he looks
does look fake it's like wow all right
in a cage because he looks like older
and they try making him look younger
with his like incredibly dyed hair his
hair is so so black so black it doesn't
look real at all no um but I really
liked it a lot because you know I
enjoyed I enjoyed his Johnny I feel like
as the Multiverse is opening up in the
MCU it'd be so much fun Nicholas cages
I was like dude wouldn't it be so cool
if you got a cameo or if they did
another Ghostwriter like now like now
where Nick Cage is at now all I'm
thinking is the movie The unbearable
weight of massive Talent was so good and
I'm thinking now as him how would he
play it now as an actor and if they made
like a new one because I really like
this and there's some like I feel like
there's moments that yes it could have
been better and maybe better uh
more well-directed especially with like
Ava's character it was like what's going
on there that it could be better written
so now what if they like redid it yeah
it's true I mean they want there's
always talks of them redoing Ghost
Writer really matter of fact Brian
Gosling threw his name in that and the
ringer for saying he would love to play
Ghost Rider like and then would Ava come
back
yeah is that why it pitches like I saw
the way Nicholas Cage was looking at her
yeah
um because yeah I I think this movie it
captures a good like Supernatural cheesy
goth horror action Vibe it's like yeah
it's fun and I and the thing is I don't
feel like it it's not aware of what it
is like that's the thing is like it's
something that you can kind of laugh
with because it feels self-aware it
doesn't feel like it thinks it's cooler
than it is at least that's my version
Vision that's how I viewed it yeah I was
watching I was like this movie feels
self-aware uh with its music cues and a
lot of its comedy and the way a lot of
it's directed like it feels intentional
and a lot of it's cheap fees so I was
able to watch it as like a b movie pulpy
uh silly movie that occasionally looked
really cool yeah like when he divorced
from the the ghost back to him in that
one shot I'm like dang it looks so good
and I mean he does it multiple times but
there's one specific one where it's like
it goes it's it's awesome yeah um that a
lot of the facts are really really good
like when they kill that guy and then he
turns into like black and then lava like
on the ground what yeah that was awesome
there was a time in the 2000s where they
were doing like these darker comic book
movies like I saw reacted to Constantine
here which is very Supernatural demonic
horror they had Daredevil which I think
is the same guy who made the Daredevil
if I I might be mistaken about that but
they had Daredevil which really had that
kind of like grungy
flare about it uh that emo uh but this
this one was yeah I mean it was it was
really enjoyable I do wish we got a
cathartic payoff though with Sam Elliott
writing off with him yes like why did
they not get to fight together I don't
understand that they really set it up
but apparently he was very literal about
one last ride I'm just going to ride the
horse he didn't even do a full ride he
was like I'll escort you down the block
yeah like what I really would oh man
that would be so cool if they just like
redid it and Sam Elliott was still in it
and Ava's character was written better
and it would be kind of fun if like if
they could play up the horror like
because some of those were actually with
the faces coming in I was like oh that's
spooky but what if they even played with
it even more and made it like actually a
little jump scary if they made it
actually scary for the reboot that would
be cool that would be awesome because it
kind of had like a horror aesthetic but
not horror and tone yeah and I could
have used some of that actual demonic
horror tone because yeah I mean it's by
no means like I give it like a seven out
of ten just because it self-awareness
but it was more it was really fun but
yeah that was clearly ways you could
have made this movie better with like
the action could have been better like I
like the visuals of the action more than
I like the choreography of the action if
that makes sense like I thought the
chains were cool the bike was cool yeah
when he goes off that building oh that
was awesome that was awesome that was
really sweet but yeah the action itself
could have been executed a little cooler
yeah
um I enjoyed Nicolas Cage's performance
but yeah the the Eva Mendes she was just
was a massive joke oh that was like like
what you said like why is she coming in
and apologizing he stood you number one
he left you when you're 18 and the
pouring rain with two bags in your hands
it doesn't seem like he apologized for
that either let's see if there's nobody
sure didn't
oh here we go let's let's get it
I guess not oh my gosh there's not okay
maybe it's in the second one okay
because yeah uh we waited we waited to
see if there was a post credit scene
maybe Amazon cut it off uh but yeah that
was fun music was cool but yeah overall
the Aesthetics and production design
were pretty rad sandwich that was a rad
sandwich at the time yeah me too I want
a t-shirt like somebody leave a link and
then I'll go through it tag me I don't
know I mean I can look for it myself I
get it but like
and also the villains could have been
better like ultimately the four whatever
the elemental people were so not
essential like they didn't need to be
here for fights you're so right because
I meant to mention that one guy with the
long hair who was like constantly
drooling or seemed very quietly his
water
what did you think about that he was
water for elements because he only he
only became water once in the beginning
of the movie and my memory just goes
whoop yeah uh that guy didn't say
anything like nothing he just stood
there dripping well they needed the soul
thingy and all it required was the one
main guy Hive so bad with names do you
remember his name the one who guy oh oh
Bernard part I don't remember his name
son yeah yeah the Bennett here
Bentar like I'm gonna know I forgot the
guy was water and I saw it yeah
uh but yeah all he had to do was go to
Johnny's store and be like give me the
souls like the other three didn't do
jack [__] right and the journey to
getting the souls all he had to do was
go to him and be like
okay I see what his weakness is he's uh
he likes her right right just give me
the souls that was all he had to do this
entire time I did think it was clever
though when he did kill him like that
was a clever because I thought he was
just gonna shoot him to death right so
when he did because they did set it up
that he can't use it on him and then oh
yeah that's right he'd be filming that
was smart that was super smart and I
liked that he made the tornado with the
chain to kill the guy with wind yeah I
like that one too chain tornado was fun
the old chain the water was like very
easy I think they could have done more
with that nothing to it there wasn't he
just was biking underwater I drowned for
a minute and then I kill you like no big
deal uh I don't know I thought the wind
one was awesome to see and then
obviously the last one but the other I
don't even remember was there four uh
there was four of them in total yeah
what happened to this the first guy got
a chain wrapped around him
and maybe if they kept it to like one
villain it would have been but then we
wouldn't have gotten the wind tornado
thing true true I mean we got some like
cool visual sequences out of it uh I did
I mean did they did the cops know that's
Johnny Storm likes of the cops so that's
what they established is the cops now
know that that guy is Johnny Storm
I don't know yeah it's it seemed like oh
right because yeah because he was on the
news right he was saying haven't you
watched the news yeah like that he was
on there and that's why they came with
all the guns because they are probably
aware of his
like I mean but then his friend was like
if this gets out to the Press but I was
like I thought the cops put together
that guy's Johnny Storm
on top of that too there's all those
people in the prison cell
who yeah who who were like who have
witnessed were privy and then one of
them was left alive though the kid yeah
to where he could say
that was Johnny Stewart right yeah like
all rooms lead Johnny storm here
huh I don't know
what I mean because what do you think
should have happened with them knowing
I mean giant storms should be a fugitive
now he destroyed half of Texas right uh
he he did he uh he did a lot of like
um felonies like he destroyed buildings
ran up his motorcycle on the building
it's gonna cost like millions of dollars
like that whole building is shot the cop
cars alone yeah like Johnny Storm's
gonna be looking at a massive lawsuit
and see this the next movie should just
be him on the run him on the run while
paying court fees he's like this is what
he has to be dealing with my bills are
on fire maybe he maybe he because he's a
good guy that the second movie will open
up and he'll be like all this money I
won from jumping six black [__]
helicopters yeah I'm now giving to the
city for all of my damage and also I'm
gonna pay you in advance because there's
going to be more damage from me killing
bad Souls yeah did you like it more than
Fantastic Four yes I liked it more than
wait oh my gosh so much more fun yes I
mean absolutely I I was thinking in my
head while I was watching it if they
remade this and it was written a little
bit better uh like especially For Ava
character I and made it a little bit
scarier I'm like this could be like an a
A plus movie yeah like it would be so
awesome but it's like a big budget b
movie yes which I would give like I
would give a beat I'm still in like they
they did their job and and I liked it I
liked it a lot
um I'm just like oh there are some parts
that are like a little bit like I heard
the second one's very weird I've never
I've never seen it really I don't know I
don't remember I don't even remember
what the trailer was like it's still in
a cage right yeah okay yeah
good good good good good good howdy
howdy howdy what did you guys think
about it did you like Ghost Rider was it
a fun movie for you
surprisingly not a lot to say if John
was here to find 40 minutes worth of
content oh really yeah really so like
you're digging on me no no no I'm
digging on me digging on you not John
yeah I can't break down all the horses
for 40 minutes just can't go see I feel
like we've said what it needs to be said
if we should move on I feel like we've
broken down yeah
alrighty guys well thank you so much for
being here but before we go we gotta end
this with a patron of the day shout out
Brian Perry
Brian I wish you could be the Ghost
Rider for the real rejects how cool
would it be if there were negative
comments that show up in our comment
boxes and then what do we do we summon
our Ghost Rider Brian Perry to go after
all of them and just slaughtered them
say look in the eyes and see all those
negative comments you've left on
everyone's YouTube page and now they're
all going to be directed at you all that
bile and vitriol that vindictive nature
thrusted into their souls Brian Perry
you are the guy I believe in you to
haunt
you're the one who's Gonna Save Us you
gotta get it done man you gotta get the
chain make it go on fire and then just
slice through the meanies comments life
through the comments and slice through
them and then go after their families go
the extra mile make the family see the
bad that they've also done and then that
way it doesn't continue down the line
because Brian you're a mean man you're
cold you're a freaking monster Brian
here you go on there you're gonna
Slaughter these people then I want you
to time travel and then wow just to go
after before they were born make sure
they weren't even born but then they
haven't done anything bad yet so you
can't really use that against them if
they haven't been I have a crits like a
split timeline so it'll be like one time
flight or they can see what happens
there's a scenario here
on the the going back you know but if we
could have just stayed you could have
just stayed where you were where where
you were going with what you were saying
but you went
John should have done the show he went
over there you know and I was like still
here
thank you Brian
I think I think we made good material
out of this I think we did a good job
thank you for being here buddy
[Music]